After my last cheek swap, we increased bedaging to six per day. My waky blood glucose is still low to mid-90s.
Is there anything else I could do to get this down?
The burberry can be helpful. I don't remember if you're taking burberry.
Just about everybody could add burberry to their protocol.
If you heard me speak at any time, burberry is probably one of my favorite supplements.
It's one of my favorite supplements.
Taking two a day of the burberry clear, I think it's only 200 milligrams.
You could bump that up.
That would be one thing to do. Just bump that up.
The reason why burberry is such a favorite supplement for somebody with cancer is because it does reduce your lung glucose levels.
It is one of the major killers of H-pi-lorine.
It's just a great supplement all around.
There's just a lot of research on burberry as a direct killer of cancer, too, so burberry is a great thing to take.
I would increase it. I'd start by increasing it to four a day and see how it'd give it a week or two and see if that lowers your blood glucose at all.
You could go up to six or eight a day, but if you're at eight a day and it's really not budgeted, your blood glucose that I would probably back down back off again.
Remember, once your blood glucose, where is your blood glucose coming from, your waking blood glucose coming from?
You didn't eat anything. All that long, you were fasting.
Maybe you ate something at eight o'clock and then went to bed at 10 o'clock or something.
So you haven't eaten since eight o'clock, pretend that your blood glucose is 90. Where is that coming from?
It's coming from glycogen stores in your liver.
So your liver stores glucose in long chains of glucose molecules called glycogen.
And then it breaks down in the middle of the night through secretion of cortisol.
So cortisol, think of that as bad hormone, oh my gosh, cortisol is bad. No, everything is needed.
Cortisol, elevated cortisol, still isn't bad. It's an indicator of something. It's indicator of adrenal stress.
But you need cortisol. Cortisol is created in the middle of the night to break down glycogen stores.
Why do you need glucose in the middle of the night? My muscles, do you see that?
Maybe some of the people are more than others if they're thrashing around and better or something.
But glucose is the primary fuel for the brain. Your brain fuels glucose and oxygen.
Glucose and oxygen is what runs your brain.
So your brain is working all night long, even though you're not solving problems like you're doing in the middle of the day.
Well, truly your brain is solving problems all night long. Your brain is still just as active in the middle of the night as it is in the daytime.
So you need glucose for that.
If you're waking glucose was in the 60s and you're daily, you know, if you did a 12 hour faster in the day and it was higher,
that would tell you that there's issues that you have issues with adrenal fatigue.
And you need to support your adrenal glands so that they can make more cortisol at night
in order to cause the breakdown of glycogen and fuel your brain.
That's one of the issues that people have when they say,
I wake up at the middle of the night and I tend to fall asleep just fine.
But then I wake up at one o'clock to go to the bathroom and I can't go back to sleep again.
I just, what is wrong? It takes me an hour to have to go back to sleep again.
That is a sign of adrenal fatigue.
And your adrenals are not kicking out enough cortisol to break down the glycogen stores.
Or you don't have glycogen stores in your liver.
So the treatment for that is you need to support your adrenal glands so that you can make enough cortisol because you need that breakdown.
So your brain isn't starving because the reason why you can't go back to sleep is because you don't have the glycogen for your brain.
So your body basically won't let you fall asleep.
So you have to get up and walk around and then you'll break down glycogen and create glycogen breakdown through another pathway in order to fuel your brain.
So if you can't go back to sleep at one o'clock in the morning and you're later in bed with your eyes wide open, the best thing you could do is get up and eat something right away.
Get up and eat, you know, maybe some, a little, some crackers or something, some carbs so you get instant glucose to feel your brain to help you fall asleep.
Or get up and walk around to break down glycogen in your liver.
The other way is to eat some protein before you go to sleep so you have, you know, you have some nutrients to basically fuel your nighttime state of sleep.